[موسيقى]
عندنا ليل وعندنا نهار اذا طلعت الشمس
لانها واذا غابت الشمس جاء الليل والدول
العربيه يتقارب فيهما طول الليل مع النهار
وفي الدول الاوروبيه يتفاوت فيهما طول
الليل مع النهار وعلى القطبين يا ليل يا
نهار هذا على كوكب الارض اما الكون فظلام
دامس فالنهار لا يوجد الا على كوكب الارض
فالموجات الشمسيه تنعكس على الغلاف الغازي
للارض ويتحول الى نهار مرئي فالنهار يولد
من رحم الليل وايه لهم الليل نسلخ منه
النهار فاذا هم مبصرون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فلو ركبنا صاروخ وانطلقنا الى اعماق الكون
ما رايح نشاهد الا ظلام دامس على كثره
الشموس وسنشاهد هذه الشموس على شكل نقاط
كما نشاهد النجوم من على الارض وستكون
حركتنا متعرجه بسبب جاذبيه الاكوان فلو
فتحنا عليهم بابا من السماء فظلوا فيه
يعرجون لقالوا انما سكرت ابصارنا بل نحن
قوم مسحورون فالظلام للكون والنور للارض
لا تحسب ان النور يا زين مني وجهي ترى
يعكس بك النور مني مثل القمر والشمس كانك
وكني اعكس شعاعك واسهر الليل
عنك
[موسيقى]